[Music]
it's a pleasure for me to be back in the
uk
even virtually
my first visit to your country was when
i was a teenager in
1950
a memorable visit on any of you who were
alive in 1950 will remember there was
food rationing still going on then and i
recall
in our hotel in cambridge the waiter in
the hotel
offering my sister and me eggs for
breakfast we did not want eggs for
breakfast
and the waiter was astonished and said
don't you understand you can have eggs
you have an allotment of eggs this
morning but we didn't want eggs that was
food rationing and my memories from 1950
also include included london all of the
bombed out sites in london that as of
1950 still had not been reconstructed so
that was 1950.
i lived in the uk from 1958 to 1962
and
that was
shortly after suez
it was after the nottingham and notting
hill
race riots that were a shock your first
race riots um in retrospect what was
going on
in britain then while i was there 58 to
62 was that you were undergoing a
national identity crisis although
neither i nor my british friends really
understood it at the time
ever since then i've returned frequently
to your country my wife and i spent our
honeymoon
in britain
britain is the only country to which i
seriously considered
moving
and i have friendships with
british people going back 65 years so
those are long wonderful connections
with your country
as i said while i was living there for
those four years in the late 50s
in retrospect
you were undergoing an identity crisis
which
is the subject of my most recent book
upheaval and something that's been much
on my mind my book upheaval um took a
comparative view of
crises now
what do i mean by a comparative view
most history books
are single case studies
they look at
one country in a narrow slice of time so
you get lots of books on late 19th
century germany or mid 16 16th century
england
instead i don't write single case
studies i write comparative histories my
book gun germs and steel
compared the histories of people on
different continents
my book collapsed compared different
societies that did or did not collapse
my book the world until yesterday
i've looked at traditional societies
tribal societies compared with modern
societies
well single case study history books and
comparative histories
each has its advantages and each has its
disadvantages
a single case study can devote all of
its
543 pages to late 19th century germany
and of course can go into far more
detail than can a comparative book in
which late 19th century germany just
gets 25 pages
in a book that looks at 11 other
countries as well
so the advantage of a single case
studies you can get far more detail
the advantage of a comparative study is
that questions arise and answers suggest
themselves that would never appear in a
single case study so
think of all those books about the
american civil war we have long books
about our civil war books of 500 700 900
pages those books
because they consider nothing except the
american civil war
can devote
three pages to the second day of the
battle of gettysburg go into enormous
detail but what those single case study
books do single case accounts of the
american civil war what they cannot do
is profit from the perspective of
looking at other civil wars and so those
books about the american civil war never
asked the question at the end of the
american civil war the victors did not
kill the losers there was only one
person on the losing side who was killed
that was the commandant of the terrible
prisoner of war camp
but at the ends of other civil wars the
spanish civil war the finnish civil war
so many other civil wars the victors did
kill the losers why did that not happen
at the end of the american civil war
that's an example of the questions that
arise in comparative studies that don't
arise in single case studies and so
there's a quip among historians
if you study just one society you'll end
up understanding no society
my books are comparative studies of
history with their advantages and with
their disadvantages
my most recent book
about crises national crises identity
crisis you may wonder did jared start to
write that book motivated by the brexit
vote in the uk or did i start to write
the book just after the november 2020
u.s elections or after covid emerged 14
months ago
no my book was not provoked by those
recent crises instead i began to work on
the subject already in the year 2013
after the publication of my previous
book the world until yesterday and i was
motivated to to
write to think about national political
crises because of my experience of
crises in the countries in which i've
lived and that i know best
in retrospect when i think of the
countries where i've lived
in each of those countries there was a
crisis either going on or
i was in the run-up to the crisis or i
was living in the country in the
aftermath of the crisis for example
i was living in chile in the run-up to
the 1973 chilean coup d'etat
i began working in indonesia in the
aftermath of indonesia's 1965 genocide
when i first visited finland in the
summer of 1959 my finnish hosts were the
veterans and widows and orphans of
finland's war went to war against the
soviet union
i began working in australia in 1964 as
australia was slowly
starting to dismantle its white
australia policy and i was living in
germany on the day that the berlin wall
was erected
um any of you who think that that
correlation suggests causation may be
wondering does jared diamond living in a
country um
is that a cause of a crisis my presence
and no correlation does not prove
causation why living in countries does
not provoke crises it's instead that
countries not in frequently experienced
crises often at least once a generation
and so just by chance my living in
countries has been associated either
with the aftermath or the occurrence or
the winding dam of a crisis
those crises are gut-wrenching
histories in their own right but they
also raise practical questions of why
some countries deal better with crisis
than to other countries to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you